good morning believe nation today's
message is keep moving forward over to
you Johnny Depp berry one of the
greatest pieces of advice I've ever
gotten in my life was from my mom you
know when I was a little kid there was a
kid who was bugging me you know in
school and she said okay I'm gonna tell
you what to do she said the kids bugging
you he puts his hands on you
you pick up then your rock or whatever
you can get your hands on and you lay
him out and I felt better and it worked
so for me you know that that was a great
lesson because someone had invaded by my
space invaded my being you know and I
was doing something against me that I
didn't want to be done so I took control
the situation and I ran with it and and
many years later after being you know
turned into a product you know by a very
huge corporation that had their hands
all over me and I and I couldn't escape
it you know I promised myself that I
would continue to move forward and do my
best not to compromise in any way
whatsoever you know not not allow anyone
to put their hands on me and affect me
in that way so that's the best advice I
think I could give is just to keep
moving forward and don't don't give it
what would anybody think
just keep moving forward and do it you
have to do for you starting the business
is gonna be one of the hardest things
you ever do in your life
you're gonna come up against challenges
that you never thought were possible
hardships that you never imagined having
to endure you have to keep moving
forward you're gonna have all kinds of
people in your life tell you all the
reasons why it's not gonna work out why
you can never do this and maybe you have
that voice inside your head as well
saying I can't do this you need to keep
moving forward whatever you don't
understand my situation is different I
didn't grow up with the family that can
help me I didn't grow up with the
resources I didn't have the right
education I don't have the right
connections I don't have the financing
to get my dreams into reality you need
to keep moving forward there will be
times where you will get hit so hard
that you will feel so terrible about
yourself that you will bawl your face
off that you will have the lowest sub
confidence ever in your life because
you're pouring everything you have into
this idea and it's not working out and
you're not getting results you need to
keep moving forward there's gonna be
times when you look at yourself in the
mirror and you ask why am I doing this
is this worth the sacrifice is this
worth the pain is this worth the
struggle you better have a big dream I
need to keep moving forward
big things aren't created by people who
live their life according to other
people's expectations big things are not
created by people who stop taking action
because they're afraid
big things aren't created by people who
as soon as they come across some
adversity they quit you need to keep
moving forward moving forward is hard it
can suck it can take everything out of
you but you owe it to yourself to make
this dream that you have in your head
come out keep moving forward
so the question day today is I'm curious
what are you doing every single day to
keep moving forward leave in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Anil grandi Anil thank you
so much you're picking up a copy of my
book your one-word
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
hey guys to stay on the theme of keep
moving forward I thought I'd share a few
extra bonus clips to keep you motivated
essentially and I would say this to
anybody is that you know it's really
it's easy to to embrace hopelessness
when things seem insurmountable and yet
it's it's it's actually just a matter of
time until all of the elements come
together for things to be alright I mean
I believe that you know most difficult
situations will resolve themselves if
you are persistent and if you don't if
you don't give up entirely and that's
what I never did I never give up
surely the opening vistas of space
promise high costs and hardships as well
as high reward so it is not surprising
that some would have us stay where we
are a little longer to rest - we bought
this city of Houston this state of Texas
this country of the United States was
not built by those who waited and rested
and wished to look behind them
[Applause]
mr. country was conquered by those who
move forward and so will space comes
free nobody's going to give anybody
anything now you get out of life you
willing to put into hard work sacrifice
dedication all of these things
breathing success now I can tell you
this because you know I was once one of
the people who were assumed to be less
likely to become successful I'm from a
very modest neighborhood you know I
think you necessarily grow up with a
silver spoon in my mouth I have things
that I would sometimes not even all the
things that I need but it's important
for you to know your environment does
not define you unless you allow it to
the position right now the position
you're in right now does not dictate
your future unless you allow it to you
can look at your life as it is right now
if you can look at it you can say well
I'm not well and it's a is what my life
would need you can do one of two things
you can use it as an excuse to do method
or you could use it as motivation to
push yourself or the choice is yours I
need you guys to understand and believe
that anything in life is possible
whatever it is you want to do it's
absolutely possible I don't care how
much trouble you've gotten into up until
now I don't care how many things you may
have done wrong I don't care how much
you may not have in your life
you can do it if you believe in yourself
enough to make it happen if you put
enough if you put enough up with an
energy and invest nothing to future you
can do anything in this world if you
want to do anything is possible don't
never let nobody tell you what you can't
do I started rapping when I was nine
years old nine years old and I'm from
Atlanta so at the time when I was back
there there wasn't no other rappers in
Atlanta and I heard every excuse why I
couldn't be a rapper I heard every
excuse why I couldn't be famous
everything from you to skinny maybe go
platinum
I heard all these things a whole bunch
of excuses a whole bunch of reasons why
I should not believe that I could make
but my belief my belief overcame that
doubt because I believed in myself but
somewhere along the line you changed you
stopped being you you let people stick a
finger in your face and tell you you're
no good and when things got hard you
started looking for something to blame
like a big shadow let me tell you
something you already know the world
ain't all sunshine and rainbows it's a
very mean and nasty place and I don't
care how tough you are it will beat you
to your knees and keep you there
permanently if you let it you me or
nobody is gonna hit as hard as life but
it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward that's how weird it
is done now if you know what you're
worth the glottic dealt with you
but you gotta be willing to take the
hits and not pointing fingers saying you
ain't where you wanna be because of him
or her or anybody cowards do that and
that ain't you
you're better than that